alex jones et un complotiste notoire qui
a fondé informers un site où il diffuse
depuis des années des conspirations
toutes plus insensés les unes que les
autres
attentats du 11 septembre
une fabrication des gouvernements
les démocrates des organisateurs de
réseaux pédophiles mais l'un des pires
faits d'armes d'alex jones concerne la
tuerie de samedi au camp en 2012
j'ai
fait
une fusillade dit il qui est une pure
invention avec des parents qui ne sont
que des acteurs payés et les enfants qui
n'ont jamais existé
dans ce premier de trois procès intenté
contre lui par des parents des victimes
il s'est retrouvé confronté à ces
mensonges avec le témoignage de la mère
du petit j'ai situé dans la fusillade
pensez vous que je suis une actrice de
monte carl est loïs non répond t-il
cruel aussi fut le témoignage donné en
semaine le père de jesse
mon fils a bel et bien existé dit il
j'ai été béni de le voir vivre pendant
six ans et demi
face à ce réquisitoire alex jones se
reconnaît que la fusillade a eu lieu
mais trop peu trop tard disent les
parents qui demandent 150 millions de
dollars en compensation pour la détresse
émotionnelle infligé intentionnellement
il reste qui hier l'avocate des victimes
a lâché une véritable bombe en cours
l'avocat d'alex jones lui a envoyé par
mégarde une copie numérique de tous ces
messages reçus et envoyés sur son
téléphone
oui des messages qu alex jones disait ne
pas avoir reçu en sa possession
comprenez vous ce qu'est le parjure
demande l'avocat alex jones médusé
des courriels et textos que voudrait
bien obtenir aussi la commission d'
enquête sur l'insurrection du 6 janvier
2021 car alex jones était l'un des
organisateurs de rassemblements de
partisans des échanges de messages
pourrait incriminer certains hauts
responsables ils vont voir
son ex femme qui allie jones qui se bat
devant les tribunaux pour la garde de
leur enfant veut aussi obtenir ces
messages divulgué il croit que ses
connexions avec le 6 janvier seront
dévoilées y avait un certain
[Musique]
que je suis sur le jury a finalement
décidé d'octroyer 4 millions de dollars
en dommages à la famille qui poursuivait
alex jones ce qui est très loin des 150
millions espérés mais le complotistes
est loin d'en avoir fini avec la justice
ici frédéric arnould radio-canada
washington